please welcome back to the show molly
simms
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
i'm going in
winning
totally um okay you have a daughter now
and there is um
there was a she's gonna destroy me about
literally
wow she is
so okay so
i am in the shower
it is team field day which means you are
a color i did not pick the color i know
she doesn't want to be on the white team
with her brother she doesn't
can i wear
a crop top i call it a crop i'm 90. yeah
no midriff crop yeah
a sandy duncan sandy duncan and she so
we did the sandy duncan
sandy
you can't do it
so i'm in the shower
she takes my phone she literally finds
her teacher starts texting
can i wear the in statement as a belly
shirt but it is you cannot you cannot
read can scarlet where where
skins go what but
so she texts her teacher can scarlet
wear a belly shirt she i love that it's
haha go for it girl she thinks it's me
like i'm like what anyway
[Applause]
scarlett stole my phone i was in the
shower
this is not me
yes she's going to kill me tell us about
your podcast lipstick on the ring
lipstick on the rim right thank you
really great title
and so let's put lipstick on the dream
it's called lipstick on the rim we talk
we drink and we talk about beauty and
wellness and i do it with my best friend
mr gormley who's living now in new
jersey with her three young girls and we
bond we connect we talk
you know everything we have like you you
get so many amazing experts on and so to
have i am the listener
going along as you are when you're with
people like i'm learning i'm learning
from
the pimple popper or dr will cole or
what are the best products do you do
botox i love the pimple popper you do
like i i know there was a video they did
about popping things on the lips i was
like and i was like oh god i can't stop
watching i know i had
um jordan geller who's my
endocrinologist i had a massive thyroid
problem i didn't find out until i was
i weighed 204 going into cedars on june
19 2012. i didn't realize i had a i
don't know how i didn't realize
i had a massive thyroid problem so i
have gone to him for the past like 10
years and just learning about hormones
and thyroid and like
it's it's been fascinating it's helped
me i didn't know that
my hair was falling out and like you
don't know the questions to ask or the
people to see so things like that that i
can help women and men but also talking
like just also being girlfriends and
sharing the connection of really lame
superficial things about the best
lipstick
so
it's good i mean one of the things i
love about you is your sense of humor
your lack of judgment and just the way
that you live your life out there it's
so refreshing i'm always so drawn to
your light
[Music]
you